of us day one and there's political and
Business Leaders meet in the Swiss ski
resort conflict in Ukraine is at the top
of the agenda the forum's opening
address coming from the first lady the
message the rich famous and influential
gathered here need to do more
you're all United by the fact that you
are really very influential
but there's also something that
separates you
are using this influence
or sometimes you use it in a way that
divides even more as the delegates here
digested the latest pictures of
Devastation from Ukraine the Deputy
Prime Minister thank Britain for
pledging tanks and weaponry and said
Germany should follow its lead
so we are grateful for our partners and
for UK who will be
among this country that will provide us
with a heavy weapon right that was the
tanks everything that we need to obtain
the victory during this year do you have
a message for Germany who have been
talking about whether they're going to
be sending extra heavy armaments
including tanks to Ukraine but still
haven't got that over the line yet I
hope that they will make a right
decision and they provide this
with the tanks with a how frustrated
that it's taking so long uh yes as I
told you so we hope that they will make
this decision they will follow your
example
in the corridors of power here in Davos
however there is another enemy for the
ukrainians growing weariness among their
allies talk to the delegates here and
you get almost a sense of relief Davos
is back there are people they say it's
almost like things have returned to
normal but the message from the
Ukrainian delegation is no this is very
much not normal a thousand miles from
here you have Europe's biggest war since
1945 and if they stand any chance of
winning it they need the help
of all the people here
one radical idea for how to provide that
help comes courtesy of Bill Browder a
longtime critic of the Kremlin my big
pitch this year is that in after the war
started the West froze 350 billion
dollars of Russian government Central
Bank Reserves it's money held at the
bank of England at the Federal Reserve
in the U.S at the European Central Bank
um the Putin regime has created more
than a trillion dollars of damage to
Ukraine and so it seems entirely moral
and logical that that 350 billion
dollars has been frozen should be seized
and should be used for the defense and
reconstruction of Ukraine it's a nice
idea the problem is it depends on the
west coming together to turn it into a
reality and the longer the war rages the
greater the Temptation for Davos man to
want things to get back to normal
at Conway Sky News in Davos